[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the new
untitled fantastic beasts film more
specifically
we're going to be discussing a theory of
mine that the film could introduce us
to a new school of magic the third
fantastic beast's installment has been
long awaited by fans
having been postponed on multiple
occasions
with an original proposed release date
of november 2020
the films just seemed to keep getting
pushed back next
to november 2021 and then to july
2022 this was for a number of reasons
including a rewrite and issues arising
from the state of the world
in 2020 however i for one am happy that
warner brothers enrolling
are taking steps to improve the
franchise which
based on the previous two installments
wasn't particularly well received
in mid-2021 we still don't know that
much about the third installment
however jk rowling did drop a massive
hint
in an old tweet during the time period
that she was rewriting the screenplay
twitter user darfcontoya tweeted rowling
with
oh my god us brazilians are freaking out
right now
are you preparing something for us to
which rowling responded
let's just say i really ought to be able
to spell rio de janeiro properly
given how many times i've written typed
it in the last few months
and where is rio de janeiro why brazil
of course
what this tweet tells us indirectly is
that we can expect to see a lot of
brazil
in the new film germany as well as it
turns out
if you want more information on the
german side of things check out my video
on that which i'll link in the pinned
comment
so what can we derive from this news
what's the significance of brazil
well as it turns out brazil is the home
to another
magical school one that only some of you
may have heard of
the wizarding school of castelo bruscho
castelo brushu is a brazilian wizarding
school that's located amid the amazon
rainforest
in northern brazil and it's home to
students from all over south america
the school itself is just as old as
hogwarts at least according to
pottermore
and was founded 500 years before
colonization
the physical structure of the school
forms an imposing square of golden rock
that resembles a temple but to muggle
eyes the school is simply a pile of
ruins
protected by enchantments much like
hogwarts
like hogwarts the south american student
body of castello brushu
wear a uniform however their uniform can
be easily identified
by the bright green robes outlined with
patterns including yellow lines
red rings and blue triangles it has also
been expressed
that the students of the school are
particularly versed in the subjects of
herbology
and major zoology we don't know for sure
if the school is going to be in the
fantastic beasts franchise
but we do know that armando dipit the
hogwarts headmaster preceding dumbledore
meets with the headmistress of castrolo
brushu benedita
dorado sometime in the 20th century
could this overlap with the fantastic
beasts timeline
if they go to brazil but don't introduce
the school in some way
i'll be surprised what do you guys think
let me know in the comment section
below until next time there is plenty to
be learned even from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
you